let's take some questions here we have  any questions here yes r- a lot to each  other on screen but name one thing that  you like about the other goodnight  everybody thank you I really I mean  there's a lot of we're negative towards  each other a lot and it works on camera  but Jordan really enjoys something I  admire about him he really enjoys life  and I do admire that about him I do  admire he really loves food he loves  travel and he's one he's spent pretty  much all of his money to the detriment  of his marriage on traveling the world  and seeing things and so I really I  really admire that about you and it was  I would say that we had a good time on  this trip together but we did oh it's  your turn go ahead employee Conan is the  funniest man I've ever known he doesn't  get out a lot  you